and for the people that live near Bonita
Vista unfortunately this is not a
surprise it's something so tragic took
place here
it was set up like this before it was
out here all day long and they never
talked about anything and now I'm coming
home and I say it again Janice Miller
not surprised driving up to her
neighborhood Saturday as a domestic
dispute turned deadly occurred at one of
her neighbors homes this happening just
before 3 30 p.m Saturday afternoon North
Las Vegas Police confirming that a man
and a woman in their 40s are now dead
and while it's still unclear who shot
who the weapon used was a gun the Bonita
Vista neighborhood blocked off for hours
as several neighbors were seen waiting
alongside the curb near the entrance
many stating that because police
activity is so frequent in the area they
didn't think anything of it we see cops
up at the house before
we didn't know what it was for but on
this street particularly behind me in
the neighborhood across from us there's
a lot of activity with landolins or
paramedics sometimes there's
parties going on
um or just you just hear fighting
somebody yelling at somebody or
screaming at somebody going on North Las
Vegas Police telling eight news now that
there was a 15 year old witness to the
whole ordeal a neighbor sharing that
when kids are involved it makes the
entire situation even more heartbreaking
Chris who lives across the street says
that's why he makes an effort to talk to
his own kids openly about the dangers
out there fortunately we have a health
relationship in our home and you know
they don't really have to witness any of
that stuff you know myself I Come From
Brooklyn home myself and so that's why
we're you know we're we're involved in
in having talks or conversations and so
they have an awareness
this is the second domestic violence
dispute to take place this week now we
asked several neighbors if they knew the
couple personally all of which said they
knew the couple from a distance
reporting live in North Las Vegas
Madison Kimbrough 8 News Now